man nannte hannes meyer einem
psychopathen einen betrüger einen
kleinen krämer man sah in ihm aber auch
den radikalen innovator passioniert
direkt authentisch hannes meyer
polarisierte als mensch und als direktor
des bauhauses in dessau
zwei jahre bei anhand von 1928 bis 1930
walter gropius begründer des bauhauses
hatte ihn zu seinem nachfolger als
direktor ernannt
später ab eine intrige befeuert die zu
seinem haus vor führen sollte
eine männerfreundschaft die sich zur
gegenseitigen verleugnung steigerte sagt
annemarie ag vom berliner bauhaus-archiv
eine feindschaft die von walter gropius
ausging
also er hat veröffentlichungen zum
bauhaus getätigt er hat eine große
ausstellung im moma 1938 auf die beine
gestellt und dort hört und sieht man von
hannes maier nichts also er hat seine
sicht der dinge er hat seinen bauhaus
vorgestellt man muss aber auch umgekehrt
sagen dass hannes meyer sein bauhaus
auch selbst genug dargestellt hat ohne
seinen vorgänger zu berücksichtigen es
ist also wie soll ich sagen eine
angelegenheit zwischen diesen beiden
männern um das war auch eine persönliche
ländern
das fängt schon bei der herkunft an
gropius stammt aus großbürgerlichen
kreisen studiert architektur hannes
meyer macht eine maurerlehre und bildet
sich selbst weiter
[Musik]
sein vater stirbt früh er verbringt als
kind jahre im waisenhaus
[Musik]
meyer ist politisch links unterstützt
die genossenschafts bewegung von 1919
bis 1921 lange vor seinen bauhaus jahren
baut er die siedlungsgenossenschaft
freidorf in muttenz gemeinschaftssinn
und zusammenleben sind die prämissen der
wohnraum soll für kleine leute
erschwinglich sein
sein soziales engagement wird er später
am bauhaus noch mehr betonen
so macht sich meyer einen namen als
architekt seine entwürfe sind derzeit
voraus
[Musik]
walter gropius führt währenddessen das
bauhaus in dessau zur blüte und große
namen seiner zeit als lehrer
etwa wassily kandinsky paul klee
oskar schlemmer
und 1927 also auch hannes meyer
gropius kann froh sein diesen ehrlichen
kerl als neue blumen seien knobloch zu
bekommen sagt oskar schlemmer
doch der ehrliche kerl ist ein harter
kritiker von gropius dem er vorwirft im
bauhaus dem luxus bedarf zu dienen statt
dem volk gropius in einer 200
quadratmeter großen villa wohnt und
darin den großbürgerlichen lebensstil
zelebriert so sieht er die zukunft des
wohnens technologisch auf dem neuesten
stand
aber natürlich mit dienstmädchen meyer
baut hingegen die laubengang häuser
entwässerung 48 quadratmeter für eine
vierköpfige familie
das muss 1929 genügen um die wohnungsnot
der weltwirtschaftskrise zu lindern
[Musik]
das bauhaus wird zur angesagten
hochschule
viele studenten sind links zu links für
die sich zuspitzende politische
situation als antibürgerliche insel
macht sich das bauhaus verdächtig und
meyer erst recht
[Musik]
1930 wird der druck immens
es droht die schließung des bauhauses
mayer soll sich nicht mehr politisch
äußern und die linken umtriebe seiner
studenten unterbinden
doch er weigert sich seine sturheit
gefährdet das bauhaus deshalb will man
ihn loswerden josef albers wassily
kandinsky und walter gropius arbeiten
hinter den kulissen gegen ihn im august
1930 dann die fristlose kündigung die
studierenden protestieren für ihn die
lehrer kollegen hingegen attackieren ihn
[Musik]
meyer selbst gibt heftig zurück man hat
ihm das sicher auch unrecht getan aber
man muss bestimmte aussagen dass er
selbst ein ein gerütteltes maß an schuld
wenn man dieses wort überhaupt benutzen
möchte selbst hatte daran dass er
gegangen worden ist er wurde mehrfach
vom bürgermeister zu gesprächen zitierte
unsere hat hausherr wurde gewarnt
er hat einfach weiter gemacht er hat
diese warnung nicht akzeptiert er hat es
drauf ankommen lassen
nach dem rauswurf besteht sein leben aus
gescheiterten träumen meyer wandert in
die udssr aus bleibt aber dort als
stadtplaner wirkungslos
auch in mexiko beschäftigt er sich elf
jahre mit urbanismus
bauen wird er nur noch ein einziges mal
ein kinderheim im solothurnischen
mümliswil für ihn als ehemaliges
heimkind eine besondere aufgabe
[Musik]
walter gropius immigriert 1937 in die
usa nimmt dokumente aus dem bauhaus mit
um sich als dessen erschaffer feiern zu
lassen
also er hat sich ein arsenal aufgebaut
um eine geschichtsschreibung dann auch
vorbereiten zu können er hat sich auch
die menschen ausgesucht die dann die
geschichte des bauhauses geschrieben
haben und natürlich aus dem
quellenmaterial heraus dass gropius in
zur verfügung gestellt hat von da war
das eine starke lenkung mit hannes meyer
ist das so leider nicht möglich
meyer war es nie wichtig an seiner
eigenen legende zu arbeiten
er starb verarmt und vergessen 1954 in
der schweiz